this morning on the dish the wonders of
wood-fired pizza
and a special visit from the youngest
iron chef in history mark forgione
mark started working in the kitchen as a
kid alongside his dad today he runs
three restaurants and is building a
fourth
as he constantly refines his approach to
simple but exceptional
american cuisine
on a scorching summer day you'd think
the last thing you'd need
is a portable wood oven blasting out
even more heat
it's always nice to be surprised as we
watched chef mark forgione
began assembling a masterpiece starting
with the best dough
in the world nice i mean i couldn't have
planned this any better i mean obviously
you can see that she wants to be on tv
creating a sourdough starter and keeping
i call it her her alive
it's almost like a baby you have to feed
her every day
i sing to her sometimes you know there's
been times where she doesn't look so
good and like i you know i talk to the
to the jar
this is not the dough that you throw six
feet in the air
sourdough is different because it gets
its yeast from the air
making each chef's so-called starter
unique in flavor and texture
pizza made from sourdough is tangy and
temperamental
as you can tell she has an attitude so
if you start throwing her around she's
going to get upset
done right it's also sensational the
first dough that i threw
into our wood-burning oven at peasant i
mean i literally started to do like the
jig
after after i tasted it i couldn't
believe it i mean it was good
it was just like ah
[Music]
forgione's work with sourdough comes a
decade after his arrival on the national
cooking scene
and the historic mexican chef final
challenge is over here in kitchen
stadium
at age 31 he became the youngest iron
chef
winner in history
[Music]
he was already running restaurant mark
forgione open in 2008
but the iron chef victory propelled him
to superstardom
early this year he turned his attention
to a new york institution
peasant peasant serving rustic italian
food in lower manhattan was run by the
legendary frank de carlo
until de carlo decided to step aside
late last year
i mean it's a crazy hollywood scripted
story he called me in like august
and he was like you know hey mark you
remember you said
you loved peasants so much and i was
like yeah of course you know why he's
like you want it
and i said yeah well sure and you know i
think this was like on a wednesday and
he's like i need to know by friday
and i called him back on friday and i
said okay de carlo's last service at
peasant was new year's eve
forgione took over the first week of
january two months later
the pandemic hit and changed everything
i'm looking at this crisis right now you
know probably
the best way i think i can look at it is
like a forest fire
and after the forest fire you know from
the ashes comes life
forgione's restaurants like so many
others right now were doing limited
outdoor seating so we had time to ask
him to make us
a feast cheers brother thank you so much
for having us
burrata with cherry tomatoes from the
vine
chicken with roasted onions and oregano
eggplant sandwiches with buffalo
mozzarella
rigatoni mezzy arabiata an aperol spritz
with orange garnish
and most importantly the pizza i mean
look at that thing
gorgeous and then something that i do
even with my
plated dishes i kind of like to take the
ingredients that we've used
and almost do them in like a raw state
so we had that roasted zucchini
so then i'll just put okay some raw
zucchini and the heat will just kind of
almost wilt it because we slice them
real thin
and then obviously we had the pecorinos
that was grated that cooked i just take
a little fresh pecorino
gives it a little texture and then just
to remind everybody that this is a
beautiful wood-burning oven i take some
smoked
salt and obviously
we hit it with oil right before it went
in this is just so you get that
gorgeous grassy notes from the olive oil
you've done this a few times and then
this is up for debate how many slices
you want to cut this into
if it's just two people you can get away
with four but this is a good way to
share
and then this is the beauty yeah this is
the beauty of sourdough first of all no
flop
yep okay no flat and then look at
the crumb you see that gorgeous gorgeous
it's almost like
like a souffle like a cake i mean it's
just you know we actually serve this
believe it or not
um with a side of a rabiata sauce so
that after you're done eating the pizza
you can then take the crust and dip it
into the arabiata sauce
so some say papa john's invented that
but we're just trying to make it a
little better
it looks a little bit better with
respect to paw patrol with respect to
papaya
now i'm starving are you kidding me that
you didn't bring any
that's ridiculous it was made fresh that
should have been
have been my dish jeff because arabiata
is my thing oh the dipping the every
spice sauce
nice we're done with you but great job
jeff
great job i want to go eat outside at
peasant now just to get a little taste
of any of that
great job mark and great job on the
dutch team by the way
marie marcy dan everybody fantastic